hi my name is franklin and today i'm
going to talk about translating chinese
into morse code
you're probably familiar with morse code
it was the way of sending messages on
telegraphs in the 1800s
the original encoding scheme really only
contemplated
um characters from the latin alphabet so
letters a through z
as well as numerals zero through nine
and it sent
each of these as a series of electrical
impulses that we represent here as dots
and dashes
as the telegraph network spread across
the world it was relatively
straightforward
and new encodings for different
alphabetic languages and so
you might have letters with diacritics
that would be slightly different
but in 1871 when hong kong and shanghai
were connected to the international
telegraph network
they had a problem that being
that chinese is a character-based
language and with
thousands and thousands of unique
characters and so the same strategy
doesn't really work um a telegraph
operator working in english
can memorize what a through z are and
can transcribe
messages as they come off the wire and
that would be unfathomable
unfathomable to do for something like
chinese
so what ended up happening is that these
first telegraph lines were built
by european companies being the
great northern telegraph company of
denmark and the eastern extension
anc telegraph company of the uk and
since they were european companies in
the 1800s they naturally chose some
europeans
to come up with the code there were a
couple of different iterations
uh the one that we're seeing here on the
right is the chinese telegraph code of
1871
uh which was put together by a french
customs officer
based in shanghai named vaguely
and the general approach was that they
took the most commonly used characters
and so starting with about 5 400 of them
although this grew up to about 6 800
um and they mapped each of them to a
four digit
code so zero zero zero zero through nine
nine nine nine
and if we look at a concrete example if
we take
the character dong which means winter if
you look that up
in a code book you'll see that it has
the value of 0392
which then you can use the like normal
international morse code representation
to to turn
into dots and dashes and
i built an app i have this link here
i'll i'll have it at the end as well
um that basically like steps through
through this and so
you can put in a bunch of chinese
characters and it'll give you
the corresponding morse code
um so
this has some implications you might
notice that with four digits we can
actually
represent 10 000 things and so we have
quite a bit of extra room
um these code books were arranged in a
way for search ability and so given
a character you could based on its
characteristics find the right place in
in the book
um and then look up what what the digits
were
um when they arranged the book they
ended up
leaving a bunch of extra spaces which
you can see here on on the right
um just in case in the future um they
needed
sort of to add new characters that i
came into vogue
um without having to kind of reshuffle
everything
the second implication is that uh it was
actually fairly slow
and verbose so if if we go back to
the um international morse code
you'll see that this is actually
arranged mostly for english letter
frequencies and so ease are very common
and
therefore very short whereas y's and z's
are quite a bit longer
and digits than themselves are pretty
long
um if you're trying to send a single
chinese character that is represented by
four zeros then you're on the hook for
20
long dashes and telegraph messages were
also priced by length and so
you would be paying for for all of that
so in addition there was this kind of
weird situation with plain text and
secret messages
so in english um telegraph operators had
developed a set of kind of special words
that were not
commonly used to to represent
longer phrases that they might come
across so if you got a message that said
toothbrush
what this actually meant was that your
telegraph uh your telegram had been
delayed in transmission and this was
great because it was less expensive it
was faster
but the telegraph companies were not a
huge fan because this cut into their
profits
so they developed a set of regulations
where
um plain text messages were priced
differently from secret ones
where the sort of like meaning wasn't
immediately obvious and
these prices were much higher per word
uh so as an english speaker like
uh you had a choice between do i want to
send this message
as plain text or in in secret
and while this originally had had
nothing to do with chinese
uh it was kind of caught in the
crossfire because chinese
was intermediated by these digits um
it had no choice but to be priced but
but to be lumped in with all of the
secret
messages which meant that it was even
more even more expensive
um this problem ended up going away
eventually uh
in 1893 the government of the chinese
republic
and the qing dynasty negotiated a
regulatory exemption
and made it so that if you were sending
a message
with chinese characters in a code book
um then it would be priced as as plain
text rather than as secret
which is an improvement um
so here we have the telegraph book or
sorry the telegraph code of 1871.
um it works but definitely has some some
drawbacks there were a bunch of
different ways that people tried to
improve on this and i'm going to dive
into one
which uh is referred to as trigraphs
so a trigraph is basically just a fancy
word for three alphabet letters
um as we noticed before digits are
pretty long in in morse code but letters
are much shorter
and so if we were able to map each
chinese character to a sequence of
letters then that would be
a lot faster and we can actually do
better because we don't need nearly as
many
uh letters uh we actually only need
three
which gives us more than enough uh space
to kind of represent all the letters
that we want
and so this is great going back to our
example of winter
the trigraph of apb is much shorter in
in morse code
and this isn't just a fluke if we jump
back to the website
we'll see that this poem originally in
in morse code
uh sorry in in digits when we switch
over to trigraphs
is like half the length
um and this is true for a bunch of
things
so that seems great
um there was a catch though so when this
was
developed originally latin characters
were not very widely understood
in china and so um the
code books had a mapping of latin
characters to chinese ones that were
phonetically similar
so instead of a b c you had i b
and c and that was great because it
meant that the operators could work
entirely in
in chinese they could look up the these
characters like like they were on the
right
um each of those boxes has the trigraph
kind of in the top left uh and then the
digit representation
in the bottom left and then the
character itself on on the right
um eventually um this mapping between
latin and chinese characters became less
necessary as
kind of exposure to to latin letters
uh was more widespread and so
eventually disappeared out of code books
and cool so to give a very concrete
example of
we have a phrase i like eating bows
which we have the conceptual equivalent
in chinese and we can see that you know
the digit representation in morse code
is fairly long
and with trigraphs it's uh actually like
probably just about the the same length
as the english phrase
which is pretty cool
we've talked about two ways that uh
chinese was encoded to morse code both
of these
had an intermediate step where they were
translated first to
digits or to trigraphs
and this extra step is is um still
common
um so 100 years later um
if you find yourself trying to type
chinese on a computer
or into your your phone it's actually
not that different
you you might be using some some type of
romanization
um and rather than a person searching in
a book for
the the right output it's um
it's your computer but we're still kind
of a step
a step removed um and chinese is
is weird and different when you compare
it to english or other alphabetic
languages
and so that's all i have um
thank you so much i encourage you to
check out the app and play around with
it
um for non-chinese speakers i have a
bunch of pre-loaded
phrases and poems that you can kind of
click around with and like get a sense
for for
how this all worked um i highly
recommend this book the chinese
typewriter
which goes into a lot more detail about
both like morse code stuff but also
just all the different ways that people
tried to create a typewriter for chinese
which has a lot of the same types of
problems
and yeah that's about it thanks